now the wind is welcoming everyone in to
learn pro tips and techniques from the
professionals themselves through a
series of master classes so joining us
today from lakeside we have chef david
middleton to teach us about simple
seafood cooking thanks for being here oh
thank you for having me and thanks for
bringing this beautiful display we're
going to get to work in a minute here
but let's talk about this master class
and what people can experience and learn
if they come to it
so the the program is basically to try
and help people become a little bit more
comfortable with cooking seafood not a
lot of people feel that comfortable
doing it at home so i'm going to do a
couple of dishes that are
from the menu on at the restaurant as
well as just some kind of tricks and
easy steps that you can do at home so
any home cook can do it that's great and
anyone is welcome to these classes you
don't have to be staying at the win
right that's correct you can just call
uh concierge or email concierge at win
and uh anyone can come and it doesn't
matter your level of expertise i mean
i'm down at the bottom so can you teach
me from the ground up of course if
you've got a great attitude i can always
teach anyone with very little skill so
okay well let's get to it you said this
is one of your favorite dishes right now
on the menu tell us a little bit about
what we're making and then we'll we'll
see how it comes together okay so this
is a seared diver scallop okay uh with a
coconut broth okinawa yam a little king
trumpet mushroom and snap peas and we
pour a little of the broth tableside
so i've already pre-seared the scallops
so we're gonna go ahead and put these on
the plate okay great these are you uh
these are 10 20 diver scallops from new
jersey so super's fresh nice and meaty
and in the class will you teach everyone
how to even you know cook these from the
very beginning absolutely
absolutely all right what are we adding
next so this is the okinawa yam that we
pre-seared it's super sugary it has some
starch to it nice body and then we're
going to go ahead and add a little bit
of mushroom
which we've pre pre-seared off nice and
roasted and then we have our uh snow
peas which are a little bit thinner than
snap peas but add a nice crunch and some
freshness to this this dish is actually
dairy free but does contain a good
amount of fat with the coconut broth got
it and then to garnish the dish uh we're
going to use a little pickled fresno to
add a little bit of heat
some people
love heat some don't so we could easily
leave these off but i like a little bit
of a punch
on the back end gonna add the fun pop of
color too correct and then we'll finish
the dish with a little basil oil and
then and then the broth so uh i'm
actually gonna have you pour the broth
oh okay all right we're doing the easy
stuff
what we're gonna do it's not that easy
you to pour it here so it pushes the oil
to the left okay there's a technique to
it all right
so do i start slow yep
right there and then just keep going
keep going all right we're doing it
a little bit more looking good perfect
all right awesome very very good this is
great this is truly like a five-star
meal so this is something that people
will learn if they come to your master
class right this is one of the dishes i
am going to showcase there as well and
that is coming up in august right august
18 thursday and if people want to sign
up they can just call or book through
the concierge and you guys make it easy
for everyone perfect yep that's exactly
right that's great well this looks
delicious i love lakeside by the way
it's just so beautiful the food is
delicious you guys you guys are killing
it over there so thanks for being here
and go check out the master class and
again for reservations it's best to call
the concierge at
702-770-7070 or make a reservation by
email at concierge services at
winlasvegas.com rocky over to you